I've been hearing a lot about micro feminism
then I wanna add some of the feministy
micro feminisms that I like to drop in to everyday conversation.
Firstly, teach a man to fish
this actually comes up a lot
men like to bring up the classic idiom slash moral teaching
teacher manta fish and you whenever men bring this up,
which is weirdly often and I'm sure you'll start noticing it
just the way that if you get a car
you start seeing it everywhere
you will start noticing how often men bring up the teacher
manta fish analogy.
I interrupt and say teacher manta fish and you emasculate him
I think that this is a far more superior moral teaching to any other
teacher man to fish metaphor.
It is far more accurate than any other one I've ever heard.
The teacher man to fish metaphor was clearly invented by men
because women know that if you actually tried to teach a man to fish
as a woman, he would feel emasculated and you might die
or at least you would suffer from being patronized and
or kicked out of the fishing club.
The next one is quite simple.
I merely just asked men to bring me things
and when they specify what things
I say I don't know things
the next one uh, is just that whenever god comes up,
I refer to her as she or they for example,
what star sign are you? Me.
I'm a Gemini. Oh,
so you're a two faced bitch?
No, I believe that when god made me a Gemini,
she meant it in a multifaceted bisexual way.
Next one. What were you wearing?
When men tell me a story where,
you know, something happened to them that was unpleasant,
I simply ask, well,
what were you wearing? You can expand on this.
Why were you there? Were you drunk?
It sounds like you're asking for it.
You get the picture.
The next thing is that if I hear a man talking in an angry voice
like on the radio or on TV or just in general,
I just simply refer to him as shrill.
Does the trick.